el 8 de diciembre indique que esperaba
obtener
de millones de vacunas en los brazos de
los brazos de las personas en los
primeros seis días conseguimos esa meta
la semana pasada el 10 58 cuántos días
antes de la meta estimada ahora queremos
llegar a una segunda meta y es buscar
otro día
para administrar todos 200 millones de
vacunas más eso es 200 mil de vacunas
encendidas sé que es ambicioso es
duplicar nuestra meta original pero
ningún otro país en el mundo se está
acercando ni siquiera cerca a lo que
hemos logrado creo que podemos hacerlo y
hoy hemos hecho un inversión histórica
para llegar a nuestras comunidades más
vulnerables y de más riesgos como
consecuencia del virus al invertir 10
mil millones de dólares más para
lograrlos también establece una meta
antes de asumir el cargo de obtener una
mayoría de hacer que la mayoría de
escuelas
de quien era el octavo en abiertas en
los primeros 100 días ahora gracias a la
gran cantidad de trabajo hecho por
nuestra administración los profesores
los padres los funcionarios locales y
estatales han podido hacerlo en las
escuelas
encuestas recientes han mostrado que la
mitad de nuestras escuelas metas están
abiertos cinco días a la semana todavía
no es la mayoría pero estamos cerca
creo que en los días que nos quedan
podemos enfrentar esta meta ayer hasta
ayer más de 100 millones de pagos de
1400 dólares han entrado de las cuentas
bancarias de las personas eso es dinero
real en el bolsillo de las personas un
alivio inmediato y muchos millones más
estarán obteniendo su dinero pronto hay
una nota final ya que aprobamos el plan
de rescate estadounidense
estamos viendo nuevas señales de
esperanza en nuestra economía
jacques desde que fue aprobado una gran
mayoría de analistas económicos han
incrementado sus proyecciones
significativamente sobre el crecimiento
económico que va a ocurrir este año
ahora están proyectando que se excederá
el 6% de crecimiento en el producto
interno bruto y sólo esta mañana supimos
que hay una gran cantidad de personas
que están pidiendo seguro desempleo que
este número cayó
en 100.000 personas esta es la primera
vez en un año que los números caen a
cifras menos menores a previa de la
pandemia así que todavía muchos
estadounidenses afuera del trabajo
muchas familias que están sufriendo y
hay mucho trabajo por hacer pero puedo
decirle a ustedes el pueblo
estadounidense que la ayuda ha llegado y
la esperanza está en camino ahora me
alegraría recibir sus preguntas
así que soy siret press
gracias presidente ha mostrado su
progreso en el auditorio quiero hablar
de otros temas que están frente a su
presidencia uno de los desafíos
definitivos que enfrentará es como
entregar cómo cumplir su promesa a los
estadounidenses en reforma de migración
en control de armamentos derechos de
votantes y cambio climático todavía hay
mucha oposición partidista los
republicanos que está de lejos está
dispuesto a llegar para lograr esas
promesas que él hizo por estadounidense
bueno mire
cuando asumí el cargo decidí que era
bueno una propuesta bastante básica y
simple me eligieron para resolver
problemas y el problema más urgente que
enfrenta por eso de unidense lo declaré
de inmediato era el kobe 19 y la
desubicación económica de millones de
estadounidenses por eso es que he puesto
todo mi enfoque iniciando hay muchos
problemas pero todo mi enfoque en lidiar
con esos temas particulares los otros
problemas que estamos discutiendo
migración a armas y las otras
situaciones que he mencionado son temas
de largo plazo han estado ahí mucho
tiempo lo que podremos hacer dios
permita
es empezar a enfocarnos uno en uno a la
vez se ha migración sean armas o alguna
otra serie de problemas que está
enfrentando el país pero el problema
fundamental es hacer que la gente tenga
un buen estado mental algo de paz para
poder ir a dormir en la noche y no mirar
hacia el techo pensando en que han
perdido su seguro médico o que perdonar
a otro miembro de la familia que estarán
en una posición donde no cuando se
pueden perder su hogar porque no pueden
pagar su hipoteca o los millones de
personas que pueden resultar expulsadas
de sus hogares por la incapacidad de
pagar un arriendo
vamos a pasar esos temas uno a la vez
tratar de hacer lo más posible
simultáneo que se pueda pero esa es la
razón por la cual me enfocado como lo he
hecho y esta es la situación creo que
mis colegas republicanos van a tener que
determinar si o si no queremos trabajar
juntos o si deciden que la manera en la
que quieren proceder es simplemente
bueno decidir dividir el país seguir con
estas políticas de división pero yo no
voy a hacer esto voy a seguir adelante
voy a asumir esta situación es como
vengan señor presidente pueden su
presidencia ser un éxito si usted no
puede progresar en esos otros cuatro
desafíos cambio climático migración el
control de armas derechos de votantes
planes va a ser progreso en todos pero
eso debe decirlo el pueblo
estadounidense y creo yo dudo bueno de
pronto usted lo hizo pronto otros no lo
hicieron yo creo que muchos pensamos que
no había posibilidad de que lograra
pasar esta ley sin los votos
republicanos es algo muy importante
eso fue aprobado una economía en
crecimiento la vida de las personas está
cambiando ya veremos qué pasa todo lo
que sé es que me han contratado para
resolver problemas resolver problemas no
crear división
qué bueno qué tal
gracias señor presidente usted ha dicho
una y otra vez que los migrantes no
deberían venir a este país en este
momento que no es el momento para venir
ese mensaje ahora está siendo recibido
pero la percepción suya que bueno estoy
feliz ido como un hombre moral decente
esa es la razón por la cual muchas
migrantes ya están viendo el país
confiando en usted con cómo resolver esa
atención y cómo está eligiendo qué
familias se quedan y qué familias deben
irse dado el hecho de que incluso con el
título cuartitos en familias que se van
a quedar hay una línea temporal para
cuando no estemos viendo estas estas
instalaciones manejadas por las tutorías
migratorias llenas de personas con
menores acompañados bueno creo que
debería sentirme contento de que la
gente venga porque soy una buena persona
eso es lo que está pasando lo que sea
que se esté diciendo que por eso vengan
porque bailen es un buen tipo me siento
halagado la verdad es que nada ha
cambiado
muchas personas vinieron 28 por ciento
del incremento de los niños en la
frontera en mi administración 31% en el
año anterior en 2019 antes de la
pandemia en la administración trump
esto sucede
cada año singular hay un incremento
significativo en la gente que llega a la
frontera en los meses posteriores a
bueno enero febrero marchó pasa cada año
en adicción con eso
en adición a eso realmente alguien está
sugiriendo que hubo un incremento 31%
bajo otros porque era una buena persona
y porque estaba haciendo cosas buenas en
la frontera esa es nuestra razón por la
cual viene la razón por la cual vienen
es porque es el momento en el que pueden
viajar con la menor posibilidad de morir
en el camino por el calor en el desierto
en primer lugar en segundo lugar vienen
por las circunstancias en el psuv país
y la manera de lidiar con este problema
y yo he empezado con la salida con esto
antes siendo senado de los eeuu como
vicepresidente creando un plan
bipartidista de más de 700 millones para
entender las causas raíces por la gente
porque la gente está yendo que hizo
trump trampa a cabo con ese patrocinio
él no lo utilizó no lo hizo
en adición él desmanteló todos los
elementos que existen para lidiar con lo
que ha sido un problema y seguirá siendo
un problema y ha seguido siéndolo por
mucho tiempo
de hecho él cerró
a cabo la cantidad de camas disponibles
él no le dio patrocinio a la salud para
sacar a los niños de esos de esas
instalaciones fronterizas donde no
deberían estar no habría estar más de
unos cuantos días un poco tiempo pero él
desmanteló todo eso lo que estamos
haciendo ahora es intentar reconstruir
reconstruir el sistema que pueda bueno
recibir bueno adaptarse lo que está
sucediendo ahora y quisiera creer que es
porque soy un buen tipo pero no es por
lo que pasa cada año déjenme decir otra
cosa si ustedes observan esto en las
cifras de personas que vienen la gran
mayoría la mayoría aplastante de
personas que llegan a la frontera y la
cruzan están siendo enviados de vuelta
están siendo enviados de vuelta miles
decenas de miles de personas que son
mayores de 18 años que son solteros
personas uno a la vez si llega han sido
regresados a casa estamos enviando a la
gran mayoría de las familias que están
entrando
estamos hablando de hacer que funcione
con méjico la voluntad de asumir más de
esas familias de regreso pero eso lo que
está sucediendo en lyon están cruzando
la frontera y aquellos que la cruzan que
son infantes y compañeras estamos viendo
los rápidos para hacer algo pero eso fue
desmantelado por ejemplo de todos los
niños que llegan a la frontera más de
70% son de 16 o 17 años no estamos
hablando de gente que le quita a los
bebés de los brazos a sus madres son
niños de 3 años que están en la frontera
creo que esos son menos del 1% que caen
en esa categoría de los mucho más
jóvenes lo que estamos haciendo es
proveer
espacio de nuevo para que estos niños
salgan de las instalaciones de la
patrulla fronteriza donde ningún niño
debería estar ahí más de 72 horas y hoy
fui por ejemplo utilice todos los
recursos disponibles fui al departamento
de defensa y el secretario de defensa
acaba va a ser disponibles
5.000 camas inmediatamente disponible 5
mil camas en la frontera de texas
estamos reconstruyendo la capacidad que
debió haber sido sostenida y que debió
haber sido desarrollada que trump
desmanteló esto va a tomar tiempo
lo otro que estamos haciendo debo
agregar mencionado una respuesta muy
larga porque si no quiere los detalles
no mire yo no sé qué tanto detalle
quiere usted sobre inmigración de pronto
voy a detenerme y quiero hacer una
pregunta de seguimiento si puedo leer un
poco sobre qué familias
la familia porque a las también se les
está permitiendo quedar respecto del
filibusterismo algo que ella se ha
estado preguntando migración es un tema
importante cuando se trata con el
filibusterismo pero también los
republicanos están aprobando acta tras
acta ley tras ley tratando de restringir
los votos los derechos electorales de
acción europea ha dicho que es una
amenaza existencia de la democracia
porque no respaldará una regla de
filibusterismo que resuelva temas como
votos electorales o migración jim
playmon alguien que usted por supuesto
conoce bien ha respaldado la idea de
esta regla el filibusterismo cuando se
trata de los derechos civiles los
derechos electorales
mire voy a lidiar con todos esos
problemas las inquietudes que bueno las
prioridades van llegando a mí voy a la
primera pregunta la primera de la
segunda por supuesto es que tal si
lidiamos con las familias o como están
volviendo con ellos porque algunas no
están regresando es porque en méxico
están negándose a recibirlas están
diciendo que no los recibirán no a todos
estamos en negociaciones con el
presidente de méxico creo que vamos a
ver un cambio ahí
todos deben volver todos deben volver
las únicas personas que no vamos a dejar
ahí del otro lado del río grande por sí
mismas sin ayuda son los niños en lo que
estamos haciendo ahí es un punto
importante que debemos entender sé que
ustedes lo entienden no estoy diciendo
lo de esta manera un punto importante en
el cual debemos enfocarnos es que la
gran mayoría de personas bajo los 18
años que llega a eeuu viene con un
número telefónico en una manilla un
número telefónico o en su bolsillo en
los eeuu una madre un padre o un
familiar cercano un abuelo una abuela lo
que estaba sucediendo antes es que
literalmente estaba tomando semanas y
semanas incluso meses antes de que
cualquiera pudiera recoger este teléfono
y llamar para ver si de verdad hay
alguien ahí weeps bueno hemos
establecido un sistema ahora donde en 24
horas ha habido una llamada telefónica
mientras ese niño cruza la frontera y un
sistema de edificación está en lugar
empezó hoy para determinar rápidamente
si o si no hay una persona traficante de
personas o si realmente es una madre o
un padre o un familiar cercano se está
estableciendo inmediatamente eso sí de
hecho es una madre o padre el padre dice
que hay un caso extremo bueno tengo un
certificado de nacimiento y llevamos al
niño directamente a ese padre
inmediatamente eso va a reducir
significativamente hay dos maneras para
reducir la población infantil en
circunstancias no aceptables como ser
retenidos en una estación de patrulla
fronteriza una es llevarlos al lugar
donde tienen a un familiar y establecer
una fecha para hacer una audiencia la
segunda manera hacerlo es ponerlos en
una instalación de salud y seguridad que
tiene casa de casas y camas licenciadas
en todo el país así como por ejemplo los
recursos federales como ford place para
hacer que lleguen con seguridad un lugar
en el que puedan ser cuidados cuando se
mientras se determina su destino el
vídeo va a ser el mismo respecto a esto
a esta medida creo que debemos volver a
una posición bueno a como ha existido
cuando yo llegué bueno cuando llegó los
estados serán el senado de los eeuu
soria requerirse para el filibusterismo
hay una tarjeta con estadísticas voy a
dárselas pero seguro los conocen es que
solía ser que entre
hubo 58 emociones en total para romper
el filibusterismo en todo ese momento el
año pasado nada más hubo cinco veces más
esa cantidad está siendo abusada de una
manera gigante por ejemplo solían ser
que uno se paraba y hablaba y hablaba y
hablaba y hablaba hasta que uno
colapsaba y saben que la gente se
cansaba de hablar se cansaba de colapsar
el filibusterismo se rompía y bueno era
difícil obtener un voto de quórum yo
respaldo movernos en esa dirección en
adición con tener una mente abierta
sobre lidiar con algunas cosas que son
solamente elementales para la
funcionalidad de nuestro gobierno como
el derecho a votar como el derecho
básico a votar
hemos enmendado el filibusterismo en el
pasado pero esto es la situación como
ustedes han observado soy una persona
bastante práctica quiero que las cosas
se hagan
quiero que se hagan consistentemente con
lo que le hemos prometido al pueblo
estadounidense con el fin de hacerlo en
el senado que están cincuenta y
cincuenta tenemos que llegar a un lugar
donde yo tenga 50 votos para que la
vicepresidenta pueda romper este empate
o yo obtenga 51 votos sin ellos yo voy a
decir algo un poco extraño nunca he sido
pobre a la hora de calcular cómo hacer
las cosas en este senado eeuu la mejor
manera de hacer algo
si es algo importante para uno para
ustedes
y uno quisiera bueno poder bueno
sí sí hay un completo cierre y caos como
consecuencia del virus turismo debemos
ir más allá de lo que yo estoy hablando
bueno esperen un momento
gracias señor presidente para hacer
seguimiento sobre el filibusterismo
usted cree que debería tomar 60 votos
acabar el filibusterismo legislación o
51 si podemos acabarlo con 51 no
tendríamos problema con la regla actual
va a ser difícil hacer que haya un fallo
del parlamento que permita que los 50
votos acaben el filibusterismo la
existencia del filibusterismo
pero esta no es no es mi campo las
reglas del parlamento pero en esta
preocupación con el filibusterismo es
completamente legítima mientras tanto
hay mucho que podemos hacer mientras
discutimos qué vamos a hacer con el
cluster ismo
[Música]
acabo de llegar a ese punto bueno
cecilia vega
quisiera volver al tema migratorio por
favor ha dado listas de las razones para
eso la gente viene discutiendo países el
problema nacional es siglos anuales el
fin de la administración periodo previa
de un reportaje de trip to the border
conocía y yo sé en el de nueve años que
camino desde honduras a estaca junto con
otro pequeño tenía ese teléfono con él y
pudimos llamar a su familia su madre
dice que ya envió a su hijo a este país
porque ella cree que usted no está
deportando menores sin compañía como
cristian por eso es que ella le envió un
solo señor usted culpa a la
administración exterior pero es su
mensaje diciendo que estos niños
se les permitirá llegar a este país que
está animando a las familias como la de
jose para que vengan
mire
y la idea de que la idea que voy a
explicar algo que no haría pero si un
niño sin compañía determina la frontera
los vamos a dejar morir de hambre y
quedarse del otro lado
ninguna administración ha hecho eso
excepción de la de trompo y yo no voy a
hacerlo yo no voy a hacerlo por eso es
que he pedido a la vicepresidenta de
eeuu ayer que lidere
el trato el enfoque con las razones
fundamentales por eso la gente deja
honduras guatemala el salvador en primer
lugar es por terremotos inundaciones es
por la falta de comida es por la
violencia de pandillas es por una gran
cantidad de cosas que cuando yo fui
vicepresidente tuve la misma obligación
de enfrentar con estos niños que
llegaban puede tener los efectivamente
trabajando con los jefes de estado de
esas comunidades para hacer cosas como
bueno lo tienes
la gente no podía salir a las calles
porque bueno sus niños no podían recibir
en golpes lo que yo pude hacer era no
darle dinero a los jefes de estado
porque muchos eran corruptos puede decir
bueno necesita que haya luz en las
calles para que su camino ponga la luz
tenemos son contratistas tenemos la
energía tenemos la luz tenemos el
contratista no tiene que pasar por el
gobierno y los crímenes violentos se
redujeron en esa ciudad
- personas buscaron irse cuando el
huracán o cuyo los dos huracanes
ocurrieron en vez de ir a ayudar a las
personas de una gran manera para que la
gente no tuviera razones para irse en
primer lugar porque no tenían hogares o
agua o cualquier tipo de sostenimiento
no hicimos nada vamos a hacer mucho en
nuestras administraciones vamos a gastar
esos más de 700 millones de dólares al
año para ganar gas cambiar la vida y la
circunstancia de la gente que se va en
primer lugar esa madre no se sentó
en la mesa de su cocina y dijo bueno
tengo una gran idea lo que voy a hacer
es que mi hijo vaya a eeuu y se aseguren
cómo fue que tiene nueve años también
conocí un niño de 10 bueno va a mandar a
ese niño de 9 años lo voy a mandar en un
viaje de mil millas
porque es un buen tipo y él lo cuidara
más desesperado deberá hacerlo las
circunstancias deben ser horribles así
que nosotros podemos hacer algo al
respecto eso es lo que él dice la
vicepresidenta va a hacer lo que yo hice
cuando el presidente obama me pidió que
fuera y lidera con esto
yo estaba en turquía en ese momento él
dijo tienes que volver a la casa tienes
que volver al país y encargarte de esto
y creamos un plan tuvo impacto la
pregunta aquí es cómo empezamos a
proceder a lograrlo lo que hacemos bueno
no hay una respuesta fácil
hay un pequeño seguimiento que quiero
hacer usted quiere ver que estos menores
no acompañados se tiene que ellos se
queden en el país o deberían ser
deportados eventualmente bueno el juicio
debe ser hecho bueno si este niño tiene
uno tiene una madre en casa y una razón
gigante por la cual debería volver a su
hogar una gran razón
hagamos su seguimiento usted ha
mencionado hijos así es que deben ser
horribles
las instalaciones de la patrulla
fronteriza en texas está al 500 por
ciento más y casi todos son niños no
acompañados hay niños durmiendo en el
suelo están saturadas estas
instalaciones ahogado con hablado con
abogados y muchos niños no han visto el
sol en días cuál es su reacción a estas
imágenes que han salido de esa
instalación particular es eso lo que
está sucediendo aceptable para usted
cuándo va a ser arreglado esa es una
pregunta en serio que si es aceptable
por favor por eso es que vamos a estar
pasando a mil de esos niños rápidamente
a otros lugares presos que hable por
plos por eso es que hay mucha gente
trabajando para tratar de encontrar
acceso adicional para que los niños
puedan es con seguridad usualmente los
niños particularmente unidos para que
con seguridad puedan alojarse mientras
hacemos seguimiento sobre todo lo que
está sucediendo eso es completamente
inaceptable
came
gracias señor presidente quisiera
preguntarle por afganistán
usted enfrenta a una fecha límite para
retiro de las tropas en mayo en mayo de
este país como candidato en tema informe
adverso se describió que ya había pasado
el tiempo para acabar estas reglas estas
guerras eternas pudo comprometer
sustento del pueblo estadounidense de
acá para el 2 de mayo eeuu ya no tendrá
fuerzas en afganistán
la respuesta es que va a ser difícil
enfrentar esa fecha límite del primero
de mayo en términos de buenos razones
tácticas es difícil sacar esas tropas lo
que hemos estado haciendo lo que yo he
estado haciendo y lo que secretario
blinken estaba haciendo
es reuniéndonos con aliados con esas
otras naciones aliados de la otan que
tienen tropas en afganistán también
y si nos vamos vamos a hacerlo de una
manera segura y ordenada estamos en
consulta con esos aliados sobre cómo
proceder y de sectario blinken tiene un
encuentro en bruselas con esos aliados
de la otan esta semana particularmente
con los que tienen fuerzas ahí general
usted acaba de encontrarse con callan y
estoy esperando la respuesta él es el
líder cito en afganistán y kabul hay un
proceso liderado por la onu que está
apenas comenzando
sobre como
y terminar esta guerra de manera
mecánica pero no es mi intención
permanecer ahí por un tiempo prolongado
la pregunta aquí es cómo y bajo cuales
circunstancias debemos cumplir con este
acuerdo que fue hecho por el presidente
trump
de abandonar la región un trato que
podría no estar funcionando cómo se
lograría eso pero no nos vamos a quedar
un tiempo prolongado creo que nosotros
nos dejaremos nosotros abandonaremos esa
región la pregunta es cuando presidente
cree usted que si es posible tener
tropas ahí el próximo año
yo no me imagino que se puede hacer el
caso
bueno crecen
muchas gracias señor presidente dadas
las condiciones que fueron dadas a
conocer en las instalaciones emigrantes
de la frontera se complementa ustedes
con permitirle a los periodistas tener
acceso a estas instalaciones que están
llenas de personas me compromete cuando
mi plan esté en camino muy pronto les
permitirá tener acceso no sólo a esa
sino a varias instalaciones